- [Instructor] An object
is moving along a line.
The following graph gives
the object's position,
relative to its starting point, over time.
For each point on the graph,
is the object moving forward,
backward, or neither?
So pause this video and
try to figure that out.
All right, so we see we
have position in meters
versus time, so for example,
this point right over here
tells us that after one second,
we are four meters ahead
of our starting point.
Or for example, this point right over here
says that after four seconds,
we are almost it seems,
almost four meters behind
our starting point.
So let's look at each of
these points and think about
whether we're moving forward,
backward, or neither.
So at this point right over here,
at that moment, we're
about 2 1/2 meters in front
of our starting point.
We're at a positive
position of 2 1/2 meters.
But as time goes on,
we are moving backwards
closer and closer to the starting point.
So this is we are moving backward.
One way to think about it,
at this time we're at 2 1/2 meters.
If you go forward about half a second,
we are then back at our starting point.
So we had to go backwards.
And if we look at this
point right over here,
it looks like we were going
backwards this entire time
while our curve is downward sloping.
But at this point right over here,
when we are about it
looks like five meters
behind our starting point,
we start going forward again.
But right at that moment,
we are going neither
forward nor backwards.
It's right at that moment
where we just finished
going backwards and we're
about to go forward,
and one way to think about it is,
what would be the slope of the
tangent line at that point,
and the slope of the
tangent line at that point
would be horizontal.
And so this is neither.
So we can use that same technique
to think about this point.
The slope is positive.
And we see that all right,
right at that moment,
it looks like we are
at the starting point,
but if you fast forward even a few,
even a fraction of a
second, we are now in front
of our starting point.
So we are moving forward.
We are moving forward right over here.
And at this point, we are
at our starting point,
but if you think about
what's going to happen
a moment later.
A moment later we're gonna
be a little bit behind
our starting point, and so
here we are moving backward.
And we're done.